from Eliot Ness to Robert Kennedy
America has a long history of who Saders
against organized crime but one name is
far less known back in the 1930s eunice
Carter a granddaughter of slaves became
New York's first african-american
assistant district attorney and she's
credited with helping take down Lucky
Luciano one of America's most notorious
mob bosses it's just one of the
fascinating stories told in a new
biography of Carter invisible was in
fact written by her grandson Yale Law
Professor Stephen L Carter I wouldn't
tell an American story a story about a
hope and a story about overcoming
adversity whatever the odds and that's
only the story of my grandmother's life
Stephen L Carter's grandmother was
Eunice Hunton Carter a prominent black
activist community leader and attorney
who made her mark decades before
desegregation it's still here as Carter
told us at the historic morris-jumel
mansion in Harlem just across the street
from his Nana's home and this was her
house this was their house number 10 a
woman so famous in her day she counted
Mary McLeod Bethune and Eleanor
Roosevelt as friends I need you to pull
all the prostitution cases not a runner
on 10th Street the real-life prosecutor
even inspired a character on HBO's
Boardwalk Empire online comment threads
swiftly filled with mockery ridiculous
anachronistic that there weren't black
lawyers back then not black women
lawyers anyway but they were wrong my
nanny Eunice was real and really did
prosecute mobsters as a detective in New
York mr. mayor well I think is one of
the best detectives in the United States
in the 1930s Thomas Dewey was appointed
special prosecutor to take on the Mafia
in New York City he hired 20 lawyers 19
white men and Eunice hunt and Carter
they're all working on
own sharking and kidnapping and murder
numbers running but Eunice is a woman so
they give her prostitution so Eunice
alone in this office listens to the
citizen complaints begins to do research
by 1936 she found evidence linking
organized crime to Charles Lucky Luciano
the most powerful mafia boss in America
she's able to go to Dewey and say I've
found the evidence that the mob is
running this and he allows Eunice to
basically run this big raid where
they're gonna raid 80 brothels at the
same time and she was able to prove that
Luciano and the mob did take a cut of
money for prostitution she was the only
assistant in Dewey's office who ever
connected Luciano with any crime
Eunice's story began in Atlanta where
race riots left a lasting impact when
she was seven years old
Eunice's home life was completely
destroyed by the great Atlanta riot of
1906 were white mobs swarmed into the
black neighborhoods to burn and to kill
she was shaped by that experience and a
year after the riot Eunice said to a
little kid she met [ __ ] when she grew up
she was gonna be a lawyer and put the
bad people in jail
her parents were intellectuals and
activists they raised Eunice and her
brother to believe that with
determination anything could be achieved
they lived an incredible life for
African American people in their time I
try to imagine it myself sometimes
here's my grandmother the grandchild of
slaves who has these two parents or
these big black activists one of them is
traveling the world on behalf of the
YMCA the other is her mother is this
n-double-a-cp activist who gets sent
into places where the people have been
completely intimidated by the Ku Klux
Klan and she's all by herself supposed
to rouse the black community back into
action Eunice would rise to importance
in the Republican Party playing a role
in Thomas Dewey's presidential bids in
1944
in 1948 his party adopted the strongest
civil rights platform ever adopted by a
major party up to that time largely
Eunice's efforts and when he was on the
stump he talked about Eunice
despite her hard work some things
remained out of reach she wanted to be a
judge that was really an ambition of
hers and she thought as a good
Republican to campaign for the right
candidates that would happen one day it
never did interestingly Eunice didn't
blame race she didn't blame gender she
blamed her brother
Althea's huntin for years her junior
spoke several languages held degrees
from Harvard NYU and taught English at
his alma mater Howard University but he
was an outspoken communist in 1951
Hunton went to prison for refusing to
name names to the house and American
Activities Committee when he was
released six months later Paul Robeson
and W EB de boys were there to greet him
but not his sister for the end of their
lives they reconciled a little bit but
they never saw each other again before
they died so sad it's a very sad story
it's a reminder of what can happen when
we allow our politics to divide us from
each other that I can't get along with
you because of our sharp political
differences we should work on that you
and I invisible was truly a family
affair Lea Carter Steven L Carter's
daughter was key in researching the book
and unfortunately the world has always
been unjust but there is also always
something that can be done one of the
things that's exciting to me about
telling Eunice's story is that it fits
in with something I think we need in
these times they were minded that that
against much bigger odds there are
people who did manage to break through
I'm not suggesting there aren't barriers
today that are real but I think that the
more we study about people who broke
through the barriers of those days the
more hope we have I think for the future
now the interesting thing about Eunice
was is she was a writer at first and in
fact was the one of the first women she
and Zora Neale Hurston to be inducted in
Harlem's writers guild I was like really
amazing and then she said no I want to I
really
to make a change in the way the laws are
impacted so that's why she entered the
law what a fascinating woman and that
the break with her brother is was a real
twist in that story it's a great read I
encourage everyone to go out and buy it
because it tells you all about New York
history all about southern Atlanta
Georgia history and it really is a romp
through a who's who of the Harlem
Renaissance